good morning millennials happy friday
welcome back to the morning toast the
final one before my maternity leave hey
claude how are you doing
hello jacqueline i'm feeling somber sad
depressed
and excited for you obviously but
it's because you're gonna miss me so
much so much obviously don't get me
wrong i'm human i'm looking forward to
my maternity leave
but you know this show is the best part
of my day i know everyone loves it so a
month off is going to be hard but you're
such a hero for literally only taking a
month off and then i feel like there's
been actually a decent amount of
confusion so let's just be super clear
jackie's taking a full month off
starting today yes and there's been
confusion because like the plans are in
flux and i'm trying to give myself
flexibility so i can't tell you like
exactly but yes full month off starting
today then the show will resume let me
get you a date let me give the people a
date for when the show will come back i
believe it's march 14th it's march 14th
monday march 14th the show comes back
and for the next two months after that
it's gonna be a
rotating
orchestra of fabulous people jackie will
show up when she can and when she
doesn't feel like it she will not be
showing up and i'm going to be bringing
in ben taylor strecker brian anyone
who's in town who wants to host if
you're an influencer and you want to
come on do reach out to me we are going
to be needing lots of co-hosts so if
you're listening to this and you think
you're funny and great and you have you
know
some followers please reach out
yeah and now even with the new interface
like claude could do it remotely
obviously it's best to do a co-host in
studio but you could get a remote
co-host if you know they're worth if
they're worth the dial-up connection
yeah there's a couple people i have on
my radar i definitely and i haven't even
spoken to them about it so i definitely
want remy bader she's gonna have to do
it okay i want um oh do you know girl
boss town
no
gbt i've been dming with her she's like
an og breath or toaster who blew up on
tick tock she does she's like a
kardashian she's worse than us like
kardashian die hard and she does all
these like pr predictions on tick tock
and she does like if i was you know and
then she picks different influencers and
celebrities if i was their publicist
this is what i would do for them and she
blew up and she has really good content
and she's a toaster so i'm gonna reach
out to her i'm gonna reach out to
literally anyone who wants to come so
it'll be fun it'll be a hodgepodge of
messiness which is so on brand i'm
excited to watch it because i feel like
being a new mom is actually the perfect
format for being a toaster at least
that's what i've heard from new mom
toasters out there so on the days where
i'm not um hosting with you i'm excited
to watch and i'll come in as much as i
can i just you know i don't know what my
schedule is going to be like don't know
what else he's going to be needing and
so of course of course i can't say for
certain where i'll
be but you can also on days you don't
want to come in we can do these types of
episodes right so it'll be just you know
a new journey every day thank you for
only taking a month off i think that's
really generous of you and you could
have taken more time off if you wanted
but you are literally so bizarre because
you're still here and i
can't even fathom that like you and your
mucus plug i just can't
well i'm happy to report that i did get
a good night's sleep last night so i'm
i'm as primed and ready for my last day
as possible yesterday was really a
struggle for me
i i felt like i got no sleep but i slept
really good last night so i'm ready to
give everything that we have to the show
and i'm really gonna miss you guys i've
started to get some dms from people of
like you know end of camp vibes like
we're gonna miss you and we're so happy
for you and i'll see and it's like
really making me emotional
no it's the end of the summer we're
living 10 months for two
yeah and next summer we're coming back
there's gonna be new campers in the bunk
which is always so exciting but the bunk
won't be this bunk
no this is the last time we're gonna
podcast where we're just like two gals
living recklessly you know
yeah yeah exactly and so even though i'm
so excited for what comes next it's it's
change and it's here
i can't wait but i have thoroughly
enjoyed these last few years of doing
what we do do doing it with you
but life
my life goes on
that is like the saddest thing i know
because you're really like anti-change
beyond i know it i know it's hard for
you and i i try to embrace change i
think it's like exciting and there's
also like no other choice but you have
chosen you have chosen
not to in general not just no pertaining
to me like in life in general no life
you don't like change
no like i just want things to stay like
this forever
yeah you wish for happiness like this
forever
forever oh my god i'm literally the
child from
gratitude
yeah
um okay well we we promised to make it a
knock down drag out episode i finally
got that phrase right right knock down
dragon
you got that freeze right and also we
need to say
pennies and nickels the phrase you were
looking for
was what was the phrase
pennywise pound foolish
oh my god i almost forgot it yeah
pennywise pound foolish this week i've
had trouble like summing up my argument
because the phrase that like applies
just hasn't come to the tip of my tongue
but thanks to the toasters i know that
it's knock down drag out and pennywise
pound foolish so that's so me that's so
you you have pregnancy brain by proxy
um that's you know i'm an empath so i
feel things deeply for other people and
that's kind of what i'm going through
that's also why i've gained weight
recently like i'm just doing all of this
for you thank you so much it's like brew
also you guys have a lot in common both
of you are like pregnant by proxy
well also something exciting that's
coming up is bruno's coming to live with
me
for
who knows how long whenever you feel
like taking him back but of course we
have to ease him into the baby um i just
do want to let you know while bruno will
be here there is a slight chance that my
in-laws kidnap him like they have not
stopped texting me like when can we get
bruno because they love to help out like
theo's going to their house today to um
spend the weekend because i'm going on
tour and they
are have not stopped talking about it
they're so excited so like there's just
gonna be bruno bruno is one of those
lucky kids who have a surplus amount of
people in his life who love him and want
the best for him everybody wants to
watch bruno which is so heartwarming for
me i'm really that's the only thing
that's like bittersweet um that i will
be without broom we have just become
like so codependent over these last few
months
that he's gonna be staying with you but
i know he's gonna have so much fun and i
think he's ready for a bit of an
adventure and the timetable it says like
i could always just come and get him
like you're down the block so it's
nothing 100 but i am going to miss brew
while um just you know transitioning to
bringing everything home but i've gotten
a lot of good suggestions from people on
how to introduce
baby and dog and the suggestion is like
to give the dog a blanket that smells
like the baby
so that they get acclimated to the smell
and then when they finally meet the baby
it's like oh i know this person
and what do i do with the blanket like i
leave it in this crate yeah i think
leave it in his crate
okay cool yeah i have to pack up and i'm
also looking for tings including heating
pad you're gonna have to like set him up
nicely well i have
i have the biggest heating pad i
basically have like a heated mattress so
there's no problem but i am actually
looking forward i've thought for years
about getting a second dog and so like
this is really a good test run for me to
see if that's even something i could
remotely handle and if it's something
that theo can handle because i
i mean theo is a magnanimous king of
course but i'm really curious as to like
what the dynamic is going to be like and
if he's going to be like older brother
if he's going to be like this is my
house back off and know your place so i
actually have a feeling we are going to
return bruno to you a different dog theo
has this calming relaxed energy and
bruno is definitely still growing out of
his like energized puppy
zoomy phase and theo just has this way
of calming people down and i think bruno
will definitely feed depending on how
long he's here for i think he'll
definitely feed off of that energy from
theo and he might return to you like a
grown-up boy
well the thing is that's so funny is
when bruno is solo like he is so calm
chill like
beyond when he's with other dogs he gets
so excited so like theo doesn't know com
bruno because bruno's so excited to be
around him
you know i do
so if you return him to me any calmer
than he is all the time like he he'll be
dead
it's not a funny joke but like
you better take care of bruce knock one
knock knock what
um i will take care of bruce of course
but we can't call him bruce while he's
at my house because my in-laws who i was
just referring to my father-in-law's
name is bruce and that's just like rude
also people get so confused because
bruno's name is bruno that is his birth
name but i call him bruce sometimes and
i also call him bryce and people like
think i'm making a typo like in my
speech but no these are just the
nicknames of bryce you know i was
watching emily didonato's story and she
named her son
daughter teddy or oh sorry daughter um
theodore theodora and and she calls the
daughter teddy
and then obviously that evolved to teddy
graham and now she calls the kid graham
and people are dming her like is your
kid's name graham is his middle name
graham she's like no it's just the
evolution of a nickname it's just the
evolution of a nickname you can't stop
it you can't control it you can't plan
for it either like even when we're
picking names it's like okay so the kids
will call him blank and it's like the
kids are going to call him what the kids
are going to call him we can't predict
right remember when we were deciding
what name to come up with for michaela
we're like we're going to call her
mickey no one's ever called her that her
name is taylor swift her royal canis
like it's just not mickey whatsoever
no it's kaylor like which is
crazy which is crazy you couldn't have
ever told us that that would be your
name so that's why when people are
naming their babies and they're like
well i'm gonna name him this so that
people call him this it's like girl that
ain't how it works yeah it does work for
like jacqueline jackie though like yeah
no of course but do you think when emily
didn't ada was naming her daughter
theodora she thought she was gonna be
calling her kid graham
no but i did think she thought she would
be calling her teddy
of course and i think she does but it's
like teddy graham and then graham and
then in a few years from now we so have
forgotten about teddy like that's how it
works that is how it works yes exactly
so
fun stuff also by the time i come back
like we'll have a name
and i'm just so excited i'm also like
still really up at night like wondering
what the name of kylie's baby is
oh i thought you were gonna say like
wondering if you're 100 sure on your
name so i'm nothing's ever 100 obviously
we have to meet elsie and make sure the
name fits but we have one name that we
both really like and i i think that's it
is that like the one like i know about
like yeah
okay yeah yeah because we haven't spoken
about it in a while so yeah because like
things have been
settled
yeah no news here but i really i really
want to know what kylie's baby's name is
and i don't know when she's going to
tell us or how she's going to tell us
like people on tick tock say chip she's
having twins i don't know what to
believe anymore
she oh that she had twins yeah
that would be crazy i don't think so
there was only one hand
yeah i know and then i'm like but maybe
the other hand that we thought was
stormy was the baby and then i'm like
damn that's a huge baby
yeah these tic tac theories are not it
out of control out of control out of
control there needs to be accountability
for tick-tock theories that are false
unfounded you need to have to come
forward and say i was wrong like really
you know get in the public square and
and have to admit that you misled people
just so that you don't do it as
frequently you know 100
yeah um we have a fabulous show for you
guys today because it's oh my god i
totally forgot to sing i know it because
even though it's like you know it's a
somber friday because it's your last
show but it's also friday so i thought
i'd mix it up and do more of like an
acoustic strip down friday love it give
it to us
friday friday
gotta get down on friday
everyone's looking forward to the
weekend
weekend
friday friday
getting down on friday
fun fun fun fun
looking forward to maternity
leave
that was nice a little depressing
horrible
yeah but we are going to need a lot of
singing today considering like it's
going to have to tie us over
for a month so if you feel the power of
song come through you please don't let
me stop you also no pressure but like
this is going to be the last episode we
leave for a month so when people are
feeling like sad they might come back to
it we have to make this a knock down
drag out show okay okay well we have
some really good stories and i feel as
though we're capable of doing that so
without further ado
wait with a further further there's more
i do i wanted to let everyone know that
i recently
have been drinking a drink from
starbucks that i actually find to be
quite delicious
what is it so i asked ben a couple days
ago because i wanted to film another
coffee review and with these coffee
reviews for me now they're just content
like i don't think i'm actually gonna
find anything so i sent him some like
recommendations somebody posted on one
of my instagram comments and it was like
whatever and i just assume every drink
from starbucks is gonna be an iced
coffee so he comes back with one of
these cups and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
a hot drink doing here but this is what
it was
it was a flat white blonde espresso with
vanilla
and might i tell you it is scrumptious
and on the app it didn't have crazy
calories it's like just a regular coffee
milk but like you know their weird thing
and i think it's quite delicious it
tastes like coffee but it's not like
killing me so if you want to try this i
think it's quite good
what does it look like when you open it
is it like
white liquid
well there's foam at the top right now i
can't see it's like you know that meme
that's like what color is your iced
coffee oh okay i see that coffee it's
quite light
okay so it's milk because it's a shot of
espresso and a lot of milk okay well i'm
just glad that you're enjoying something
and that you're having coffee or staying
caffeinated hydrated and even though
it's been like six months you finally
found your answer
yeah but i will keep doing the videos
because gwyneth paltrow seems to love
them she comments on like a lot of them
and i just feel like for my friendship
with gwyneth i have to continue the
series even though i do believe i found
a drink that i like 100 no you didn't
keep going like gwyneth needs these
and this coffee journey like so me and
ben um filmed an episode of the good
dish yesterday i told you guys and it
airs next week or the week after that um
and like a lot of the segment was about
my coffee reviews they posted a lot of
my like my highlights of my
my coffee segment and so like i don't
know i just think it's good for my brand
so i'm gonna keep doing it okay good
everybody liked it it was good for your
brand don't know why you stopped glad
you're back on the train oh don't know
why you stopped because i'm the laziest
piece of [ __ ] on the planet that's why
i don't know if you knew that
um i actually don't think you are i can
think of people who are lazier i
literally know who you're thinking about
that's how we are so simpatico you know
what that's so crazy
no yeah it is crazy but you know right
of course
yeah okay but also i'm not even saying
you're the second lazy it's like you're
okay so you so you drop the ball in the
coffee review like it's fine
i know um thanks for making me feel
better about it so yes we have a great
show we're gonna recap the real
housewives of miami episode that dropped
on peacock last night in the tv recap
segment and then we're just gonna do the
fast five and we're gonna take our time
because i don't have to leave for
foxwoods for quite a bit and i don't
know i just think we should knock down
drag this out
okay yeah no a lot of pressure no
pressure no good um if you're listening
like you know in a few weeks you just
discovered this podcast like hey welcome
to the toast claudia and i are sisters
yes sometimes is
unclear is not our brother he's my
husband ben is her husband theo is not
her actual son it's her dog
and actually um
i am older than claudia which is really
i think the thing that really shocks
people
and jackie's having a son
knock wood sometime soon and that son is
a human but bruno and theo are dogs
yeah so that's just like what you need
to know here and we are full sisters
we're not just like sisters in name only
like we're sisters hundred percent
claudia has a song called hundred
percent also i also have a book it's
available at girls no job.com book it's
the story really a lot of jackie's in
there too so it's a story of our lives
the story of our career how we started
the show i also do comedy girl with no
job.com tour but if you go to
girlwithnojob.com that's kind of the hub
you can find out about all the things um
so come see me on tour and we do have an
instagram account oh we do we swear we
swear it's just gone for the time being
but we're getting really close to
getting it back and i do think by the
time i mean for hopefully by the time
the show comes back the instagram will
be back but it should come back like
while we're away so that'll be exciting
for everyone to look forward to
yeah i can't wait
yeah i know you're so excited
so okay even though like part of the
reason it's gone like is my fault
yeah but you live and you learn
you live and you learn you know and it's
not a mistake if you learned a lesson
are you ready without further ado for
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
i am and today's episode of the morning
toast is
full of somber but it is brought to you
by fit on
the convenience of working out from home
is really something that i can't
emphasize enough
stop paying to work out fit on workouts
are always free to use fit on is a
flexible platform where you can choose
from over a thousand easy to follow
workouts for all fitness levels or you
can follow a customized workout plan
based on your fitness goals if you're a
busy parent or you have a chaotic work
schedule fit on has workouts that are
short as five minutes you can always get
in your workout and feel good you have
five minutes between meetings five
minutes between changing diapers fit on
is so flexible it can really work for
anyone and there are already over 10
million people who use fit on and love
it they have the widest variety of
workout styles including cardio strength
training toning pilates yoga kickboxing
bar and more so you'll never get bored
you find something you like if you're a
creature of habit like me you'll do the
same one every time if you're
adventurous person you could change it
up every day the best part is that you
could stream it to your phone tv or
laptop and there's no equipment or gym
membership required so there's basically
no excuses they have a 4.9 in the app
store rating and more than 350 000 5
star reviews and it's been featured in
forbes us weekly people women's health
etc so it's totally free to use you can
do it in your house and there's
literally no reason not to do it join
over 10 million people getting their fit
on work out for free anytime anywhere
text toast to 64 000 to join fit on for
free that's toast to 64 000 t-o-a-s-t to
64 000. message and data rates may apply
terms available
at fit on app.com
terms and those terms apply
great thank you claudia
it's a pleasure
yeah doing business with you
[Music]
our first story adele was on friday
night's episode of bbc one and she is
addressing all of the tings talking
about her relationship
hinting that she is engaged saying that
she wants a child with rich paul she
calls her ex simon her quote soul mate
and reveals regret over what have would
have been a half-assed vegas show in her
words
so i saw a video of her performing at
the brits
and she's wearing a big-ass engagement
ring on her
left ring finger yeah so she's like
perhaps engaged she's not shying away
from that and she's also revealing that
she wants to have another baby her first
with her boyfriend rich paul next year
as she continued to fuel rumors that
they are engaged she hinted at family
plan saying quote it takes me a while to
recharge and i would like to have more
children i only just feel like i've
caught up with my sleep from nine years
ago when i had my son oh that's like
really scary for me that was nine years
ago
that's that doesn't sound right
hold on
how old is adele's son
i mean
angela was nine years old he was born in
2012. i'm shook
time flies oh
that's really shocking beyond
damn she also spoke out about the
controversy surrounding her las vegas
show saying she will reschedule them
this year and spoke about her feelings
towards her ex-husband in the interview
on the gram norton show she said that
she admitted her regret at the last
minute announcement and insists it would
have been a half-assed show if she had
gone ahead but they're working to put
together a new show that will be the
caliber that she
expects from her so she's standing by
the statement and the story that she put
out even though there have been all
these rumors flying since then that it
had to do with her boyfriend she was
having a breakdown um
okay so she's standing by i mean
honestly at this point like i don't even
care like
when it was happening it was like crazy
because there were people already on the
plane finding out and there were people
already in vegas finding out that their
tickets are no longer valid and
now i'm like okay whatever
yeah but i think all the rumors that
were swirling afterwards you know about
her relationship and just like the
crying in the pool and whatnot um i
think this show is like meant to you
know
assuage everyone like her
uh
what's the word
pregnancy brain
her appearance her appearance on the
show it's meant to just like let every
know how hi it's like it's still me
everything is fine um i'm sorry about
that which happened but it's there's
nothing nefarious going on got it and
you know i was for some reason like
really targeted with the dell content
this morning on tick tock because this
weekend we're the brits and adele's just
like having you know she's having a week
she went to the brits and then she went
out to all these gay bars and these drag
clubs and the drag queens bought her out
on stage and she was shaking her ass and
she looks like she's having such a good
time it must be so fun to be adele yeah
non-problematic queen uh pictures from
last night she went to um an event a gay
porn idol i think it was and she's like
has is in her bra having great time
she got up on the stage so i think she's
um having a nice weekend no that sounds
so fun you know i've never been to
london
i've never been either i don't know it
feels like i
like recently everyone's like we should
go to london i'm like okay i've never
been
so you should go i know i feel like a
london summer ever since i read
something blue which takes place in
london i kind of i'm like i need to be a
london girly cause you know i love a
london boy i enjoy nights in camden
shortage in the afternoon he likes my
american smile like a child when our
eyes meet darling i fancy you
took me back to highgate met all of his
best mates so you know all the rumors
are true you know i love a london boy
boy
boy i fancy you sorry you did tell me i
could sing and i do feel like i'm
already taking advantage i think that
you should and for anyone who's new here
we do sing a lot on the show less when
we're doing remote podcasting but i
think it's something that sets us apart
from our competitors i do
i completely agree like we are unique we
are not like other podcast hosts and
that's just a little bit about us
uh i was going to say you were talking
about reading you read the new colleen
hoover book i've been waiting for
someone aka you or margo to read it and
let us know how it is
um can you let us know how it is i'm
such a coho girl but i have two things
to say like you know my genre and i'm
proud of it like my genre of book is
like
corny erotica like corny porny horny
corny yeah it's the porny collins show
okay
and so
i don't know if it's because like i
haven't read colleen i've read all of
colleen hoover like in in a couple
months and now i moved on to bigger and
better things so i don't know if like
maybe i'm just too erotic now because
like i've read tessa bailey and her
books are [ __ ] wild but i was like
where is the porn like of course they
had sex like two or three times but
there were like a couple scenes where
like they were about to have sex and
then she ends the chapter and being like
the sex was great and it's like well
tell us about it like
we need to be there with you so i was
like
i don't know if my bar has changed or if
this was like a less erotic book just
first of all but i don't base a book
based on the erotica i don't
i do think though that your bar has
changed oh my god i'm like too raunchy
for colleen now is that what you're
saying i i think so i mean i remember
like i think her raunchiest book is
maybe like verity
would you say
yeah so i wonder if you read that now if
it would if it would meet your bar of
porn tessa bailey has really like she
writes
but then in terms of like the story
there was no like
big switch you know like
you know she's this girl and she's out
of prison and then you're waiting to
hear like why she really didn't deserve
to go to prison you know
you know i'm not gonna spoil it but
first of all the plot just like wasn't
really there for me i don't really feel
it felt so corny and that's like me
saying like corny but it's like the bar
back and the girl from prison like it
was just like too much for me like
i felt like and honestly if someone were
to ask me like what are you reading
right now like i felt embarrassed to say
that i was reading this book because the
title is like so mortifyingly like
corny danielle steele you know
no we facetime yesterday and you were
reading said
what are you reading and you said
reminders of him no i believe i said
reminders of him
and that title so i gave it it wasn't
bad by any means are you okay i'm just
having pain in like my pelvic area and
the laughing is hurting but it's it's
passed it just passed we're fine a
contraction no no not a contraction just
like things are happening there's a lot
going on in in the body just remember
that today is your last chance to have
your water break on the toast and i'm
just and you know we only had one ad
today so if you do break it like the
show can end and we can be in a tizzy
it'll be like zack zack get the bag like
we could do it okay i don't think that's
what's happening but just just be in
tune with your body and let your pelvic
floor just wide open okay okay okay i
will do that for you um so it was fine
like i didn't hate it and i read through
it in like two days um i gave it three
out of five stars it was just like
okay fair i'm sorry that it was a
disappointment i look forward to hearing
what snitch thinks because you know
she's like co-host number one fan i
don't think she'll like it
damn but will she admit it
no different question stub go as we like
to call her by the way for those who are
new here
margo is also our blood sister she's at
mark austria on snapchat she hosts a
podcast called the snapchat chat
what did i say you just said she's mark
austria on snapchat
oh my god that's so weird i literally
haven't used snapchat in 35 years that's
that's crazy
she's at margaret on instagram she's a
big time influencer she hosts a podcast
called the snatcher on our podcast
network called toast news network and
she recaps the bachelor and we call her
snitch and we call her counselor we
don't know why but there's a long story
we're just not in the mood to get into
it yeah and we call her snitch but not
because like of any century that she
does or does not commit it has nothing
to do with like being a snitch she's
just the snitch
no foul play
no foul play here it's not like she's
never snitched but it's not like she's a
notorious snitch or anything like that
yeah i'm sure if we looked into it she
actually is a notorious snitch
well now she is the notorious snitch the
notorious sni tch
are you ready for our next story it's
really for you and i'm going to need you
to explain to me who these people are
sure taylor holder
no who's that tick tocker who got
arrested oh no what did he or she do
it's a boy and there's just so much
conflicting like no one really knows
what's going on but like all of his
friends a couple weeks like maybe a week
ago unfollowed him and like everyone was
asking what's going on with taylor
holder no one would tell us anything and
then literally an arrest record came out
he was literally arrested in la like a
couple days ago still don't know what's
going on rumors of sexual assault but
it's not no one knows what the [ __ ] is
going on
jeez okay
um well no our next story is about two
euphoria castmates who are taking their
relationship oh yeah looking public with
dating rumors and a steamy kiss hunter
shafer and dominic fike were kissing on
dominic's instagram story with happy
birthday happy birthday um and the
internet is ablaze
yes so this is jules and elliot
and they actually like have feelings for
each other in the show so it's like very
on brand um and if you follow jumois or
like any sort of like underground like
you've known that these two have been
rumored to be have been dating for a
while so if you're an internet sleuth
you saw this picture and you were like
oh confirmation but if you have a normal
life and you
don't spend all your time on your fake
instagram account then you were probably
like oh these two co-stars are dating
how interesting and cool this is brand
new information that's me yeah
yeah and it's always good when co-stars
are dating are there any other like real
life relationships coming out of
euphoria because i think that's like
just what the show needs there's really
not there of course was a brief stint
between zendaya and jacob alorny but now
she's like so head over heels in love
with tom holland he's been spotted many
times with olivia jade which is like the
cutest couple of all time
um
so no besides this no they all are in
relationships like cassie's in a
relationship sydney sweeney with like
this older gentleman um
barbie
who plays cat is in a relationship
they're all like have their own
social lives there's also been like a
lot of whispers about
certain things
behind the scenes on
on euphoria like i know barbie i can i'm
sorry i can never pronounce her last
name ferreira
yeah i
yeah who plays cat um
she there are rumors that she's like
super she's kind of been like cut out of
the season it's so weird and the rumors
that she was you know butting heads with
the showrunner sam the guy who created
the show um
so there's no one really knows because
it's like a very tight-lipped but
there's not a lot of like intra-cast
relationship and dating you know what
that's probably good for the like
longevity of the show because sometimes
when like you get all these like young
sexy people together and they're all
like running rampant it's not
sustainable but if everybody sort of is
like coming to work and we're here to
work and it's not just like a big orgy i
think that's best for the show okay also
um because you just reminded me
obviously of riverdale when like in the
beginning when all them were dating each
other and then it reminded me of cole
sprouse and i was on tick tock and i saw
a clip from the lady gang podcast kelsey
was telling the story of something just
that happened to her recently did you
hear this no
so i guess she got an acting gig in a
cole sprouse um
production and she was like so excited
and she was posting all about it on
instagram tagging calls
and he messaged her and was like oh my
god there are all these like fake
production companies like using my name
for like all these things and kelsey's
like so i'm not getting the 30 grand in
the movie role
and he's like no i'm really sorry like
there's it's actually like a really big
problem i'm having and she was like
crushed
she was scammed
scammed
that's crazy but did she like send in
audition tapes and stuff
i don't know the extent because it was
just like a 30 second clip on tick tock
and i was howling at the moon um but
it's in one of the most recent podcasts
of the lady gang oh my god that's
hysterical that is something that would
happen to kelty that's so kelty yeah
that's that sucks
i know
well are you ready for our next story
i am
cheer star jerry harris has pleaded
guilty in the federal child pornography
case
jerry harris the season one breakout
star of the donkey series cheer pleaded
guilty to two out of the seven sexual
abuse and child pornography charges
thursday departing from the not guilty
plea he entered more than a year ago so
as part of this um
deal
he pled guilty to the two counts then
the other counts have been dropped so
sentencing will be expected on
june 28th and we will know uh
what's in store for jerry but this is
like the end of the
of the cr the president here yeah
so i mean he's been in jail for quite a
bit awaiting sentence and i'm sure covet
didn't help with the delaying of that um
so what has it been like two years that
he's been in prison
a year and a half i think
because it was like september that time
21
20. the time you spend that time you
spend in prison waiting a sentencing
does
count towards your sentence correct
yeah
time served
time served right so i'm curious like
however long his sentence is gonna be
like if he actually might be getting out
soon let's say he gets like a two-year
sentence or a three-year sentence he
could be out in six months or a year the
counts that he pled guilty on are
receiving child pornography and crossing
state lines for the purpose of engaging
in an illicit sexual act with a minor
under the age of 15.
yeah those are bad ones
yeah
but i don't know how much how much time
they each the maximum for each of those
right
counts are so we'll see
but soon we'll know the fate here that
was like the most depressing part of the
documentary and just like the whole
cheer thing in drama you see
cheers going on tour
i did i think that's such a great idea
me too i wonder if netflix is involved
at all if it's like a monica aldema
production
i think netflix is probably involved i
don't know if monica could pull that off
on her own and also if they're going to
use the
cheer
yeah i think it's a netflix to do i
think that's a really good idea like
because it's like where do we go from
here all these athletes they have such a
short period of time where they can like
make their money and be famous and be a
professional cheerleader and i think
that this is a great idea like think
about and i guess i don't even really
know the extent of like how deep the
cheer world goes until the docu-series
on netflix and there's like die hard
kids out there who are obsessed beyond
belief and it's kind of like the usa
gymnastics girls the kellogg tour right
that's what they do
oh
yeah yeah yeah they do a tour they do a
tour yeah i think i think it's kellogg
um
and so it's actually really smart i
would see it
yeah i'm sure i'm sure it'll be fun
it's just interesting how like
this show came out and like how each of
the kids are going to
you know
make a career out of it and i think that
this was a natural next step i didn't
think of it at the time when i'm like
well they're doing cameos and they're
you know becoming going on ellen i
didn't think of a tour torn i think it's
a great idea
yeah you know i think every day about
the cameo that you got me from carlin
and how there's the wedding ring the
engagement ring and the suffering and
the sound i just laugh to myself
you know what i think about every day
what
the cameo that i got from jerry harris
do you get one from him
yes i don't know i bel okay so right
before it was
what it's 2022. two years ago right
before my show at the beacon which was
my biggest comedy show ever i think it
was the toasters who all chipped in and
they were like jerry can you matt talk
our favorite comedian and he was like
yes girl you're gonna go out there and
you're gonna kill it you're hilarious
like we love you and i was like i was
shook and it was really empowering and
now it comes up in my timehop and i feel
nothing but shame
timehop is about to get
is about to get dark because we're
heading into like march 2020
timehop and it's like right now i'm
looking at my timehop life was so good
what it what's it's like mid-february
yeah yeah i think forgot the date and it
was like yeah like president's day
weekend
yeah you went to miami i went to palm
beach
and i had no idea what would happen next
it's about to get really bad over there
on time oh my god i was crying laughing
from your interview with sophia franklin
when you mentioned timehop and she said
what are you 33
beyond insulting beyond
it was so funny obviously that's not
what she meant but i was cracking up i'm
still healing those scars
that's the worst thing someone could say
to you overestimate your age
to yeah for i mean in general it's
pretty insulting but like for you
yeah because i'm like such a
self-conscious 27 year old i'm like oh
my god i'm literally one foot in the
grave
that's really how i feel are you ready
for our next story which is really a
disappointment and i i really i sh
i shudder to bring bad news to the table
today but there's bad news in the air
there's already bad news because you're
leaving us for a month so just rip the
bandaid off the beauty and the beast
gaston prequel is not going forward at
disney plus i heard for now
disney plus
beauty and the beast prequel series will
not be moving forward at this time the
decision comes as the lead cast of the
eight episode series had been assembled
ahead of the planned summer 2022
shoot in the uk so they were doing like
a gaston origin prequel series at disney
plus which is just like
a no-brainer of an idea because
obviously there's a lot more to gas
stone than what meets the eye justice
for gaston is not being served according
to sources the call not to proceed with
the show was made for creative reasons
with the scripts and original music not
coming together in the direction
expected or running behind schedule
with a number of creative elements up in
the air and the shoots start already
pushed from early spring to summer a
decision was made to put the project on
hold pushing filming further into the
fall was not an option because of talent
availability and weather concerns
this is a great just just unacceptable
make it work literally make it work
it's egregious for sure but a part of me
is like if you're not going to do it
right amazingly yeah then don't do it at
all and i hear that it's like that's
where they're at like if
they had shitty music and shitty
screenplay like nothing would be more
embarrassing for gaston than to be a
part of a farcical
prequel
yeah was luke evans involved yes and
josh gad
[ __ ]
yeah
this sucks
and i have especially as two girls who
have been out here using their platform
for years
about how gaston was painted in a
negative light
he is a hero and a gentleman
yeah no and he definitely like he's not
perfect nobody is who is jackie who is
but he he
he wasn't as bad as it was all cracked
up to be he's been through a lot
and we all have and i think that's a
story we could all relate to
yeah i agree
and we're not going to be getting this
story and that's really sad
but also i'm grateful that they're not
going to be disgracing gaston with some
shitty performance yeah exactly and so i
agree i appreciate the move here but
it's not the move that i wanted to hear
and i do feel responsible because it's
something that i was excited about i was
looking forward to and whenever i'm
invested in a project it never gets live
works out so you're saying essentially
that the downfall of this production can
be directly linked to your overall
existence my karmic energy yeah
yeah if you love something
you should set it free because it will
get canceled if you don't yeah no it's
really true like i have a long list of
things
so um you're making a list and you're
checking it twice
i'm sorry to everyone to take
yeah it's okay we forgive you
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is a really crazy story but
also really scary um with a happy ending
but still really [ __ ] scary
yeah i'm not sure if you've heard this
story yet a chicago woman was rescued
from a naked kidnapper thanks to wordle
yes and excuse me yeah a naked man crept
into an 80 year old chicago woman's bed
and held her hostage for 17 hours
but she was finally rescued after her
daughter called the cops because the
woman hadn't texted her the day's wordle
answers and i guess every day like she
would text her daughter about wordle
um denise hall was asleep on saturday
when a mentally ill man broke into her
home in
chicago according to wbbm the intruder
slipped into her bed while clutching a
pair of scissors she said she was in
shock i was trying to survive that's all
he said i won't harm or molest you he
ordered her to take a shower with him in
her nightgown and then they took a bath
instead it's just a really like scary
scenario such a horrible story for 17
hours and because she hadn't texted
about wordle it alerted her daughter
that something was wrong and she called
the police i mean this is a horrible
story no matter who it happened to but
just like it being an
older vulnerable person just like gives
me the biggest pit in my stomach
um
and obviously i'm glad she's okay but
like this is just every woman's worst
nightmare like ever yeah no a nightmare
also um at the bottom of the article it
said that wordle was developed by a
software engineer called josh wardle
and um you're kidding and i'm not sure
if that's like a coincidence or if like
he called it wordle because he's wardle
well we should find out if josh wardle
is single because homeboy just made
seven figures from selling that app to
the new york times
and you know like they're gonna make it
a paid app like that's what they do
because they're literally so [ __ ]
annoying and
i just think we should all enjoy wordle
before it gets ruined by the new york
times so like don't forget to do it
today tag me in your results i'm i'm
having a good streak but like anything
else like it'll fizzle out and
especially once they like do their thing
to it
uh whatever should we do today's word
all together
that might be like infuriating for
people why okay if you haven't done it
again
you really but this could be like 12
minutes segment well if we can't get i
can usually get it in like a few like
minutes seconds
oh look at you
no yes i feel like really hard look
they're already making changes to wordle
look at the font at the top it's new no
and also i got this oh and it says new
yorktimes.com
oh my god
yep and i just got this thing that like
explains wordle it's like i've been here
what do you expect i get that every day
i've never got that every day i've never
gotten it but now what do you usually
start with
i start to start with the same word
i start with roast
i start with great
okay we could do yours we could do yours
okay we'll do mine
roast
roast wow you guys do it along with us
okay wait you know what oh jackie
there's something i'd like to know
okay okay now i think that i like price
price here
price okay that's good
okay not bad r c and e all in the wrong
spots
that's so helpful oh um ch
cur yeah
i don't think this is gonna be premium
content claudia
me too because this is like a hard one
and now we just ruined our worlds for
the day
just we'll finish later okay okay we'll
finish later but i thought that would be
like a fun thing to do together but now
i'm thinking wordle is in a group
activity like imagine listening to this
in your car just two morons
i guess i forget that not everyone
listens to this podcast like 100 focused
like on everything we're saying like
they do other things they work
they drive
yeah but we'll get back to it we'll get
back to it later anyways um so word will
save the day here but this is an
incredibly disturbing story yeah very
sad i just you know
i'm really hating the times we're living
in more and more especially like you
like it's bad in new york the crime is
so bad but also like
traveling to other cities for tour like
you really see it's really bad
everywhere the crime is insane
yeah and like when i go to meet and
greets they're like do not walk around
here late at night like it's just
why like what is going on yeah no it's
really scary
um so those are the past five stories
and i feel as though you definitely
needed to know them you need to know
them before you embark on this weekend
and now we will get into our real house
size of miami recap i feel like we're
just like dragging our feet because it's
never taken us this long to get to the
end of the fifth story and it's not even
like you know kim kardashian went to the
moon right which definitely is going to
happen someday
1 000
so the real houses of miami was kind of
an explosive episode because
i just feel like and i want to hear
people's thoughts on it because there's
obvious there's two ways of thinking
like you understand even though
okay i'm feeling conflicted because i
definitely think larsa is lying to us
about her
relationship with kim like kim didn't
you know excommunicate her because she
knew too much that's the opposite what
we know about kim is like people who are
loyal to her and have known things about
her forever like those are the people
she values cherishes and keeps so close
to her so larsa obviously betrayed that
trust larsa didn't just get kicked out
because she knew too much about kanye
and kim like that's the type of person
kim would keep close
one thousand percent that's not why
they're not friends i do sort of feel
like but whatever relevant whatever
happened between them it might be like
larsa sees it one way kim sees in
another way it's not to like cut and try
it's not like larsa hooked up with
tristan even though like apparently
that's a runner too
um i think it's like probably confusing
for larsa because i feel like even when
it went down and they all unfollowed her
like i feel like larissa hadn't gotten
the memo that she was out yet so it's
not like something big happened but
definitely painful there was some
weirdness there i agree it's not because
she knew too much um
but things so i do think she's lying i
think she's lying about that
but that doesn't really matter to the
situation at hand where adriana is just
being an atrocious dreadful woman
full of dread that conversation when she
was like here's my life story it's my
life story i'm like what are you yelling
like that for calm the [ __ ] down
she's so unhinged and i actually like
i feel sympathy for her because she's
such a nobody and she's doing everything
in her power to be relevant and she
can't get arrested
no she is so out of control like
that dinner was humiliated
like first of all even if larsa was like
still friends with them like it is it is
weird no one wants to bring it up to her
face like kim kardashian is like the
most famous person in the world and like
if kim saw these at this episode like
she would literally
cringe so hard and like lars is sitting
there like knowing that and also yeah
adriana's telling this like dumb
inappropriate story about like disguise
were you in the men's room like walking
in honey how many times did she say
kanye west penis in the episode 45 like
it was so a thousand it was so
unnecessary and she's like embarrassing
larsa intentionally and we all know that
it's uncomfortable like i was sitting
i'm uncomfortable like knowing that like
you're talking about your ex best friend
and her husband the dynamics are like so
weird adriana and larson aren't even
close and adrian is just like a deranged
woman
overall sociopathic like literally a
crazy woman running around screaming
kanye's penis
there was nothing for larsa to do other
than to get up and leave i thought larsa
handled herself perfectly like being
like please stop talking about this at
first then being like these are my
friends this is a sensitive subject i
don't want to talk about this like i
felt like she tried and adriana was just
like there was no speaking to her and so
larsa had to leave because regardless of
what the topic was let's say you're at a
girls dinner and someone brings
something up and someone just chimes in
and it's like honestly i don't feel
comfortable can we change the subject um
imagine not doing that
no someone you've been friends with for
10 years
digging your heels in more right what
did she say she said that 10 years ago
larsa was talking [ __ ] about kim
in her interest
yeah and i feel like she was referencing
a moment on the show like in twenty they
would have showed it
they would have showed it yeah i was
waiting for them to show a clip no she
will just like say anything and now
she's like using i guess larsa i mean
maybe this was her last effort to get a
mojito and be a full-time cast member um
yeah she was like i'm gonna bring up the
thing that everyone's talking about
which is like why isn't friends with the
kardashians but as a kardashian stan
like i don't need to like it made me
uncomfortable like there's nothing here
that i need you to pick apart um
because it's just like really really
awkward and when i think back on the kim
and larson friendship i do remember like
a lot of the friendship was surrounded
around their kids
so i definitely understand larsa being
like my kids used to play with his kids
and you're out here talking about his
penis like it's just disrespectful and
it's inappropriate and i think any human
being with like a modicum of grace and
elegance and manners
would know that that's just like not
appropriate yeah and then when she goes
to gertie's event which was so nice by
the way and it was like oh my god
bothersome that lars like came off in
such a
bad light because i really like her i
wish she showed up on time and also
saved the conversation for another time
because just to come in and like be a
part of the drama is just not a good
look but adriana like again even when
she was recounting the situation to
alexia i had dinner last night
i had dinner last night with larissa and
she went like crazy on me it's like what
did you do you crazy no wait wait she
she said i went to dinner with larsa
last night she blew up at me for no
reason and alexia's like for no reason
right like everyone has adriana's number
but she's so irrelevant that it like
doesn't even it's not even worth talking
about but because she keeps bringing up
kanye's penis like larson needs to talk
to her about it and then it looks like
next week she's bringing up kardashians
again and larson leaves again and it's
just like stop
no and it seems like next week there is
this like coming
comeuppance with larsa because obviously
julia's mad at her for saying the thing
having a baby out of wedlock adriana's
obviously mad at her for a multitude of
reasons gertie's now mad at her for
starting the fight at and coming late to
her event um so it's like loserville
ganging up on larsa
but i'm still team larsa
oh so am i by the way
and i i feel like
lisa and alexia are this is so
uncomfortable for her and she's handling
it in the best way possible um yeah i
mean i think she signed up with the show
knowing like at some point this
conversation was going to be had like
what the [ __ ] happened with you with the
kardashians but i don't think she ever
for once thought it would come from
adriana saying kanye's penis is big and
thick
yeah agreed like if she were having
lunch with lisa and they were just like
talking about old friendships like
perhaps she could have
shed light on it then but the way that
it's coming up and adriana's just like
grasping at straws
and you know what like i definitely had
some preconceived notions about larsa
like for her you know she was like super
rich in miami and then moved to l.a and
became like so famous for the
kardashians and now she came back to
miami and i definitely would have
thought like she had this kind of air
about her like i think most people would
like you just feel like you're better
than everyone like you've hung out with
the kardashians for multiple years in a
row like i would think i was better than
you too like i get it
but one of the biggest takeaways i've
had from knowing more about larsa on the
show is she's actually not like that at
all she's very quiet and she's very
sweet and she's very lovely and she's
polite so
adriana being like you came back here
you think you're better than us actually
larsa doesn't act like that at all when
i would have expected her to like and so
lars is saying no maybe you feel that
way about yourself but it's not anything
i've ever done like i don't give off
that vibe that i think i'm better than
everyone she's nice to everyone i
completely agree she's nice to everyone
she doesn't talk down to people if
anything other people in this group have
that issue
i don't feel like she treats them like
she's better than them i feel like for
some of the women they feel like maybe
you know if we weren't filming like you
don't want to be my friend you don't
care about me and that's probably true
that's all these all these shows yeah
but like are
you're not going to want to be friends
with everyone sorry and there are people
on the cast who it seems like she is
friends with
in like a more authentic way like lisa
so it's like level up or we're not going
to be hanging out off camera
level up or get the [ __ ] out
also lisa and lenny's relationship was
just cracking me up last night i know
people think they're like going through
it but i actually thought their
confessional um bickering was really
funny and cute
yeah i think like it's extremely brave
to put your bickering out there as
someone who's bickered publicly many
times um
people are so mean and they're so quick
to judge even though like half of
marriage half of a successful marriage
is spent bickering it's just life so
there was nothing in that those scenes
that made me really uh
worry or question their marriage i
thought it was traditional bickering
because lisa was like yeah you know he
was a lonely child and it was definitely
um
kind of lonely for him and he was like
well i wouldn't say that but you know i
wish i think it would have been better
if i had a sibling which is basically
what lisa said like yeah no it was
really funny and on the one hand i'm
like if you can be like
honest about your bickering and you're
not hiding it and doing it in the
shadows then it's extremely healthy but
then i do think about adrian and paul
and how they that was not bickering
jackie that was a full-blown assault
like the way they would just come at
each other over plates like that was not
cute confessional bickering that was a
full-blown divorce okay because they
were like before they were getting
divorced they were like the bickerers no
and no i
as a bickerer myself i don't relate to
those two people whatsoever they were
never bickerers they were always taking
things so far bickering is not like
they used to make these grand statements
like oh i don't know why i'm here in the
first place like that's what bickering
is bickering is like oh my god you're so
[ __ ] annoying like shut up
yeah yeah yeah okay fine i just always
associate them with bickering and i'm
like well then maybe it's not healthy to
bicker in the public no your association
is incorrect
okay thank you for clearing that up
because i didn't know how to reconcile
my two ethoses here
no um so how many episodes are there and
is there a reunion
i think that was like the ninth episode
there is a reunion it's already filmed i
wouldn't be surprised if like uh no next
week's probably not the finale
uh
but i think it's coming up
actually i don't know but they did film
the reading alexia's wedding is gonna be
filmed no because they wound up getting
married in december
oh like just recently yeah the august
thing didn't go through i mean how could
it there's nothing it's july and there's
no venue gertie put on quite an event
that haiti uh charity event was
it i was like oh i would let this [ __ ]
plan my wedding in two seconds the
lighting for the fashion show was beyond
the fashion show was sickening and we've
been to a lot of fashion shows and a lot
of charity events in housewives universe
and it's pathetic do you remember oc
fashion week on the boat like
beyond a hundred percent the fashion
show like the fashions were sickening
it reminded me of project runway like
the whole thing yeah no it was so so
well done and i agree doing a fashion
show on a housewives franchise is
brave it's it's brave and she knocked it
out of the park the event was amazing
and i just wish like people were mad at
larsa i know because honestly like i'm
not i'm not feeling like she deserves
and i hope that like the og girls like
lisa marisol alexa i hope they stand up
for um larson next week
yeah but adrienne is like also an og
and i don't they don't claim her at all
they do not claim her at this point i
don't think they knew that she wasn't
gonna be a housewife
i didn't even realize that she wasn't a
housewife until you said it like this
week when we were recapping it was the
first thing i realized because i was
beyond confused because she was in the
opening scene with uh
lisa
alexia marisol they had like all the ogs
and i'm like but she's not holding a
thing in the opening credits i was
beyond confused yeah and she has
confessionals
right like kiki doesn't have a
confessional and kiki's a friend of
mm-hmm no i think they had every
intention of making her housewife and
then she stunk up the joint
i can't stand her like i really can't
she's just like she's one of those
people who's just beyond wrong which is
not a crime of course but to speak with
such conviction about your wrongness
that should be illegal
can't stand i was pulling my hair out
watching last night like i
it was peak like we've been saying like
she's you know the whoa like she makes
no sense and nobody even like gives her
pays her mind with all her
nonsense but it was just like on a whole
other level last night
100 burnham
yeah um okay so that's the end of the
show i just wanted to give you a few
seconds to see if you wanted to break
your own water cur like so we could just
get it on the podcast um i wouldn't know
how so i'm sorry that it didn't happen i
know you would have loved push really
hard
i just broke my own water push
that's not how it works it's not how any
of this works
no i know i'm just learning so much
about how it all works i know but it's a
lot of just waiting around
which is my least favorite thing to do
um so before we wrap up jackie is there
anything you want to say to the toasters
before you become a mom like before you
leave us and come back a totally
different woman
i mean just thank you everyone for being
a toaster this has been
you know
it is a dream and i'm excited to
bring a fresh perspective when i come
back and share
everything and learnings etc
and go on this next chapter with all of
you i'm
i'm excited for the future
and
it's just it's crazy it's it's emotional
but also everything makes me emotional
for sure
um
okay so i guess i wish i had like more
powerful words but perhaps when i come
back the words will flow i just you know
there's a lot
going on right now
in search of your mucus plug
you're obsessed with my i just found out
what that was and i'm just beyond
obsessed and then i googled it and
deeply regretted looking at the images
yeah i did not look at google images i
just looked at you know the
factoids
it was
beyond
um okay so like bye i guess like it's
over yeah we're wrapping up we're
wrapping up let's
lead us out claude
oh say
can you see
by the
dawn's early light
what so
proudly we
held the twilight's
last gleaming
who's brought stripes and bright stars
through the perilla
[Music]
we
watched
were so gallantly
streaming
[Music]
through the night
that our flag was still there
oh
say
does that star spangled
[Applause]
[Music]
for the
land of the
free
in the home
of the
brave
i don't know why that was just it felt
right a national anthem moment paying
respect to our country
to you to motherhood
to the super bowl watch out mickey
guyton because that's going to be hard
to top
you know i thought that was actually
pretty good it was really stunning i
think everyone is quaking right now um
that was really unexpected and beautiful
thank you for leading us out into no way
do you know why i did that
no i just had to make it about myself
for just one last time
okay
jackie we love you good luck god speed
we'll be waiting for you with open arms
toasters it's only a month
don't worry read a book we'll be back in
a month jackie me co-host ben brian
anyone you want to see dm some of your
favorite instagramers and be like
they're looking for co-hosts please
reach out to claudia like i really need
help so i love you guys thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennium morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitch or public radio i already
cast box all the places where we listen
to the podcast finance more than just
live streaming about our beautiful smart
we are
hope you guys have an amazing amazing
month off jackie i love you i love you i
mean i'll talk to you in two [ __ ]
seconds um but toasters i love you thank
you so much for all the support and love
and all the advice and just nice
messages over the last few months it's
really been um
it's been wonderful so we will see you
we'll see you soon bye
love ya bye